Speaker 1: Let's go next to Taylor from Atlanta,
Georgia. Taylor, welcome to the program.
Speaker 2: Hey, David. How's it going?
Speaker 1: It's going well.
Speaker 2: Hey, good to talk to you.
Speaker 1: Likewise.
Speaker 2: I wanted to just kind of bring up a
thought or opinion and get your thoughts on it.
I guess suggests the culpability of the NHRA is
maybe a little bit more I'm sorry, a little bit
less than what we're giving it. Okay. And I don't
mean the I don't mean their inaction, you know,
isn't maddening. But I think these issues with the
guns and like the I don't think the gun lobby has
as much power as we're saying they do.
Speaker 1: Okay. And so what why do
you on what particular issue? So
give me a little more specific.
Speaker 2: So just lobbying
the you know, the senators in
Congress want to completely reject people.
Speaker 1:
So we're losing we're losing your
audio. It's starting to get all
all chopped up. I mean, listen, one of the
things that I think is important to consider is
most Democrats and Republicans want total
universal background checks, eliminating
all loopholes to get around it. The NRA is
against that. And the NRA directly funds many of
the elected officials who are also against it.
So I think it would be natural to be wondering
what is the effect of those donations?
It seems natural to ask that question.
And it seems the effect is probably some.
Speaker 2: Yeah, I agree. But I'm saying
there is potentially other. Factors at play.
I think there is a large, concerted group of
religious fundamentalists. Yes. That have
in a way, buried themselves into politics.
And so when I see people like Ted Cruz on stage, I
essentially don't see him saying like, hey, I'm on
the NRA side. He's saying, don't vote me out. Like
don't replace me because these people have come up
with ways that they're politically successful in
that they've done the math you need. You have. A
given percentage of people that vote Republican
given their vote Democrat. And so all they
need to do is address the remaining 3%. Right.
Speaker 1: That I don't disagree with that. And
and oftentimes, the appeal to that slice, it may
be bigger than 3%, but the appeal to that slice is
based on a number of wedge issues that are not
even that important to the bulk of the voters
that regularly vote one way or the
other. That's that's the disturbing part.
Speaker 2: Exactly. Exactly. Yeah.
Speaker 1: All right. Well, thank you for
the call. I appreciate your insights.
Speaker 2: Thanks.